ne laissez aucun tag aucune trace ces
agents de propreté sont sur le pont pour
une opération nettoyage dans la capitale
après les incidents d'hier selon nos
informations le parquet enregistré
258 garde à vue à Paris Paris ou en
début de cortège un policier a été
grièvement blessé littéralement enflammé
et donc rapidement ils sont intervenus
on peut éteindre l'incendie et les
nouvelles au moment où je vous parle
sont plutôt rassurantes mais il était
quand même gravement brûlé au bras aux
mains et au visage la teinte à
l'intégrité physique clip plus elle
lorsqu'elle concerne un fonctionnaire de
l'État et un fonctionnaire de la
République française doit être beaucoup
plus sévèrement sanctionné et nous nous
plaidons pour la sévérité la plus totale
en la matière donc il y a un acte
administratif qui consiste à dissoudre
les milices antifa des groupes violents
ce sont mêlés à des cortèges pacifiques
et le désordre et le chaos mesdames et
messieurs les députés cette violence est
intolérable singularité de la journée
d'hier par rapport au 12 précédentes
c'est qu'hier il y avait un niveau de
violence dans ce pré-corpège chez les
casseurs chez les invités ultra qui a
dépassé largement le niveau de violence
qu'on avait constaté vous abîmer la
démocratie en utilisant la police non
pour garantir le droit à manifester mais
pour le réprimer votre bilan c'est la
violence ça suffit policier brûlé
journaliste frappé manifestants mutilés
les coupables c'est vous des
dégradations également dans plusieurs
villes de France comme ici à Nantes au
total 406 policiers et 61 manifestants
ont été blessés dans toute la France
selon le ministère de l'Intérieur il
nous dit le leader des insoumis le
maintien de leur dire a tourné une fois
de plus à une absurde violence générale
Darmanin on est 100% responsable c'est
pourquoi il veut reporter sa
responsabilité sur les autres moi je ne
partage pas du tout ce que dit Mélenchon
quand il parle de mauvaises République
je suis convaincu qu'il n'y a pas de
bonnes et de mauvaises République
par contre il y a sans doute des bons et
des mauvais manifestants
récupéré des projectiles qui ont été
lancés hier contre les forces de l'ordre
c'est impressionnant c'est des pavés
parfois qui font qui font 500 grammes
voire quasiment ça ça fait quasiment un
kilo le mauvais manifestant c'est celui
qui honnêtement je pense se moquent
totalement de la cause pour lesquels il
y a manifester mais qui vient armé avec
des barres de fer des boules de pétanque
parfois des bidons d'essence et qui
vient là pour en découdre entre
guillemets peu importe le flacon pourvu
qu'on est l'ivresse je ne crois pas au
moment où je joue pas avoir entendu
l'extrême gauche Monsieur Mélenchon ou
ses amis condamnés c'est violences on a
pas beaucoup entendu et j'ai bien
regardé vos plateaux de télévision hier
soir des condamnations notamment venant
de l'extrême gauche venant de la France
insoumise venant de Monsieur Mélenchon
qui lui appelle quasiment la sédition
mais où est l'extrême gauche dans celle
condamnation j'ai pas entendu Monsieur
Mélenchon condamné c'est violence au
contraire on sent bien une forme
finalement de complicité tous les
porte-parole du mouvement que trois mois
ou le coordinateur national de la France
insoumise qui a pris la parole sur votre
antenne ont condamné cette violence ont
eu des mots pour le policier donc faut
arrêter maintenant de vouloir comment
dirais-je détourner le sujet oui oui à
condamnation Monsieur Mélenchon contre
l'attaque de ce policier elle est où
vous avez raison de ce point de vue il a
fait toutes les télévisions hier
nous reviendrons également sur cette
décision très politique en Allemagne
depuis hier pour 49 euros par mois les
habitants peuvent utiliser tous les
transports en commun de manière
illimitée pour aujourd'hui on attend
toujours le mot de Monsieur Mélenchon le
silence a son histoire de selonchon même
si le rang complice des milliers de
scénaristes de télévision et de cinéma
sont en grève à partir d'aujourd'hui à
Hollywood il réclame une hausse de
salaire une grève qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences pour l'industrie américaine
du divertissement des émissions vont
être arrêtées et d'important retard vont
avoir lieu pour les séries ou les films
si vous avez écouté le discours d'un Le
Pen si si oui j'ai écouté c'est le vide
c'est vraiment c'est parti de la flemme
et il n'y avait aucune proposition
Gérald Darmanin et au gouvernement c'est
panique à bord quand on a plus
d'arguments quand on est plus dans une
dans un débat de projet contre projet
ben on a l'insulte on a l'invective on
aboie et on essaye de mordre alors
apparemment c'est ce qui a voulu faire
monsieur Darmanin ça c'est pas une femme
d'État c'est au mieux une petite femme
politique comme Monsieur Bardella est un
petit homme politique quelqu'un qui lit
des sondages et physiciens je vais être
du côté de ce qui crie à Paris le temps
est au nettoyage en attendant la
prochaine manifestation prévue le 6 juin